doomsday is here a nuclear bomb has just
Unleashed hell right in front of your
eyes
the land turns to Ash and scatters in
the wind in just moments
you have mere seconds to get to safety
but once that blast hits how could the
light burn your skin
why should you never look at the
explosion
and how can taking off your clothes save
your life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a nuke exploded near you
once that missile launches you can't
escape what's coming next but what are
you facing
well four types of energy are about to
be Unleashed first a blast wave would
rip through the landscape knocking you
around like a ragdoll and destroying
buildings after that brace yourself for
intense light followed by skin melting
heat and deadly radiation
then a hot bubble of gas will form a
fireball that will vaporize everything
inside it all that dust debris will
shoot up into the air creating the
iconic mushroom cloud
even if you somehow survived this
nightmare why would your life never be
the same again
so far only one nation has used a
nuclear bomb against its enemy the first
of the two bombs dropped on Japan by the
United States during World War II little
boy decimated Hiroshima it had the
strength of 15 kilotons of TNT
but that's nothing compared to what
nuclear weapons are packing today
the most powerful is 80 times stronger
than what hit Hiroshima
now while that would be devastating and
level everything for miles it wouldn't
make our planet a nuclear Wasteland
you on the other hand well you wouldn't
be so lucky if you happen to be in the
blast vicinity your days would be
numbered remember that intense bright
light
yeah well that flash is strong enough to
burn your skin off
these intense flash Burns can be fatal
and they killed 50 percent of the people
who died in Japan
and here's hoping you didn't stare
directly into that blast because this
devastating light would over saturate
your retinal pigments and leave you
blind
flash blindness can go away after two
minutes if the explosion happens during
the day but at night you could be
blinded for much longer
and if you weren't sheltered you may not
survive what's coming next
in just a fraction of a second the
nuclear Fireball would expand out like a
balloon Rising into the sky
the heat from that fireball would send
out a blast wave that would rip you and
the ground under you apart
if you didn't make it indoors before the
blast the supersonic wave might kill you
by ripping off your skin or sending you
flying through the air
then a violent burst of thermal
radiation would be released and head
right toward you
and unfortunately for you it's only
going to get worse
next a second pulse would hit lasting a
few seconds this time this wave would
carry 99 of the total thermal radiation
from the nuke
you could be eight kilometers away and
still suffer first-degree burns from
this detonation and all that would
happen in a matter of moments
then the resulting mushroom cloud would
Tower above everything
so what would you do now
well even if you only suffered third
degree burns the pain would be enough to
send your body into instant shock
hospitals if there were any left in the
area would be so overrun with other
victims that you might not get treated
for hours
gamma and neutron radiation would cover
everything the first minute after the
blast if you somehow lived through that
blast wave and the fiery Heat this
radiation might kill you
as the dust settles the radioactive
particles would penetrate everything
making the blast site hazardous for
months if not years
radiation exposure could lead to brain
seizures and cancer it might even reduce
the lymphocyte cells in your blood that
would increase your risk for infections
to avoid that lethal Fallout you'd have
to run and hide
you'd have about 10 minutes before the
radiation hits so hustle and get to a
concrete or brick building to shelter
you for the next 24 hours
and you're gonna want to get naked
if you take off your radiated clothes
you could remove up to 90 percent of the
radioactive material clinging to you so
the Savior modesty for another time
now since you've stripped down wash
yourself with soap and water to get rid
of any remaining radioactive particles
now there probably wouldn't be any power
left but you'd have to keep the air
conditioning and the fans off if there
was otherwise contaminated air from the
outside could come in
now no matter how safe you are you can
never guarantee that nuclear
Annihilation is far away yeah after all
the United States and Russia owe 90 of
the world's nuclear weapons so what
would happen if Russia launched a nuke
well get to the shelter and keep
watching because that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]